the Duke has provided new guarantees and
the protection of fundamental rights and
the uniform application of a law the
white paper commits the UK to membership
of the European Convention on Human
Rights
it recognizes the European Court of
Justice and the only arbiter of you law
the design gentlemen in contrast and our
future economic relationship it comes at
no surprise no surprise that finding
common ground between the you 27
and the UK is more difficult but we have
agreed already and a common denominator
we both want an ambitious free-trade
agreement the UK wants to take back
control
Domonique of its money flow and borders
and you said exactly this point in
article this morning we will respect
that but you also want to keep controls
to keep control of its money flow and
borders and the UK should respect that
the you cannot and you will not delegate
the application of its customs policy
and rules v80 and excises beauty
collection to a non-member but we have
doubts that can be done without putting
at risk the integrity of our customs
union our command commercial policy our
regulatory policy and our fiscal revenue
and on the basis that there is no deal
until we have the whole deal they will
need to be a clear time frame and
obligation written into the withdrawal
agreement to move expeditiously from
this declaration to the conclusion of
the binding agreements that will give it
effect during the course of the
implementation period
and the contours of our proposal are now
well known but allow me just to recap on
the economic side a free-trader
area for goods that avoids either party
imposing additional checks at the border
protecting integrated supply chains and
the jobs and livelihoods dependent on
them and meeting our commitments to
Northern Ireland and Ireland we also
want to see cooperation on energy and
transport and we propose a framework for
mobility that enables UK and EU citizens
to continue to travel for each other's
countries businesses and professionals
to provide services and our young people
to enjoy the educational opportunities
and the rich tapestry of cultural life
right across Europe we've agreed to meet
again in mid-august and then to continue
weekly discussions to clear away all the
obstacles that lie on our path to a
strong deal in October and one that
works for both sides